one of the basic truths of the human
condition
is that people love to float
and there's no better place to float
than here at the Dead Sea in Israel
we're without any effort at all large
mammals can achieve buoyancy there's
some ritual involved to doing this place
the right way you need to fall into some
mud lather up and then relax with a good
read sorry to do that to your white
shirt Jack you handsome devil
Israel has many wonderful sides and this
is one of its finest
Arabs Jews tourists and TV hosts all
come here
and can't help but float together for a
while and lack its unfettered or at
least less fettered joy it would be nice
if this story could remain so soon but
it can't to come to Israel is to witness
the fierce tensions that loom over this
country firsthand these spy balloons
floating by highways it's walled off and
fenced in Arab City and tourist spots
turn quiet due to the stabbings and
random acts of violence that have become
so prevalent over the past two years
on this episode of hello world I'll dig
into how the constant threat of war gave
birth to the Israeli technology industry
and how is really evolved into a
technology giant one thousands upon
thousands of cutting-edge startups
my journey will find me in Jerusalem
controlling an iPad with my eyes in Tel
Aviv using this little guy to discover
what's really in my food Isis look some
Star Trek and in Nazareth I'll meet with
a man that wants to make sure no one
gets left behind in israel's race to
animate Silicon Valley may be home to
some of the biggest tech giants in the
world but it's being challenged like
never before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet making things that will
blow your mind my name is Ashley Vance
I'm an author and journalist and I'm on
a quest to find the most innovative tech
creations and meet the beautiful freaks
behind them hello world
the Israeli military dominates much of
this country's culture in 18 years of
age men and women head off for two to
three years of required service
kids who would be trying to locate the
best kegger or sleeping through class in
the United States find themselves here
dealing with the most intense of
situations these young soldiers in the
Israeli Defense Forces or IDF also learn
to use some of the most advanced
military technology around to see how
the IDF has given Israel a unique tech
edge I decided to check it out up close
to see the Iron Dome I've traveled to
Ashkelon the coastal city just south of
Tel Aviv that nudges up against the Gaza
Strip what you were seeing here right
now is the launcher which launcher has
20 missiles on it you can see the red
light flashing which means it's armed
and ready here one of the dozen or so
Iron Dome batteries sits at the ready to
intercept missiles and provide Israel
with the type of shield from aerial
attacks the orange on commander
Lieutenant Colonel LaRon Cohen oversees
its operation is this as close as we get
or do we get this as close as we got
it took just three years and about 200
million dollars to develop this defense
system it relies on a radar that
instantly detects when a missile has
been fired algorithms quickly try to
determine what type of projectile is in
the air and whether it's heading for a
populated or strategic area
if so Iron Dome launches a missile of
its own it said that Iron Dome has taken
down more than 1,000 missiles since it
turned on in 2011
with a 90% success rate
some people question the accuracy of
these figures what's clear though is
that the algorithms capable of directing
projectiles while performing a
cost-benefit analysis on human life are
among the most advanced in the world
this network of launchers is highly
mobile and constantly on the move this
site like many is temporary
everything you see here can be moved out
in a matter of hours and we move around
a lot to make sure nobody knows where we
are all the time unless you live here
it's difficult to imagine just how much
this technology has transformed the
lives of ordinary Israelis I can tell
you from my own personal experience
sitting in my own house and seeing
rockets fired towards my house and
operating this is an incredible system
and succeeding with the Iron Dome when
you see your house that you're
protecting and your family and your
friends and your soldiers it's a sense
of greater sense of pride
for many Palestinians Iron Dome means
something else it's just the most
visible part of an expansive Israeli
security apparatus that includes drones
checkpoints and espionage technology
those tools have been put to immediate
use in the West Bank Gaza and throughout
Israel terrorist bombings have declined
missiles have met their match but lower
tech forms of protest like stabbings
are now on the rise what's been
remarkable is the speed at which young
Israelis take these types of high-tech
tools and then privatize them once they
leave the army
be at peace time or war Israeli
innovations pop up throughout the world
coming up next on hello world
we'll check out an IDF inspired startup
it wants to send laboratories to space
why do people want to do experiments in
space every day our life is dominated by
this lens of gravity we remove that lens
of gravity and we learn something
forget dull strip malls and office parts
startups of Tel Aviv come to life here
in the city's vibrant neighborhoods they
feed off the city's energy and the
employees have a chance to escape their
cubicles and live I came here to meet
one of the people that shaped the
Israeli startup lifestyle slow-mo Kramer
served in the IDF almost 25 years ago
and his first company checkpoint
invented the freakin firewall we always
had to start the Bucks we always talked
about stuff that there we will do
afterwards and it was always around
startups like a lot of israel's tech
elite slowmo got his start with unit
8200 a top branch of the IDF group 8200
right is this is this famous part of the
IDF that I guess equivalent to NSA in
the United States was like the bedrock
of everything else that have done
afterwards was it 22:23 old I was a head
of the unit you know 20 people extinct
very high responsibilities you know I
was making decisions in millions of
dollars and the idea functions sort of
like a never-ending networking event the
first question at a cocktail party is
what unit you served in for members of
unit 8200 these ties have led to Israel
dominating
for security software and hardware what
makes Israel so well-suited to two
startups and technology Israelis itself
is a start-up Tel Aviv you know there
was a hundred years ago there was
nothing and everybody kind of goes up
with the feeling that it was this zone
is that came in and created something
out of nothing which is the concept
essentially of we're all startups
there's always a infusion of new columns
form the IDF and the infusion of talent
you've got the recipe for a successful
startup nation yeah slow-mo has invested
in dozens of Israeli companies to see
the extreme end of what the IDF can
inspire have gone to Hertz alia the
small beach town and tech hub that
brushes right up against Tel Aviv it's
here that a company called space Pharma
has set out to make some interstellar
drugs
if humanity would like to move out of
earth they must learn the microgravity
conditions
you know just survive on the way to Mars
and to other places Florida CEO Yossi
Amin used to head up the IDF satellite
program then he and his comrades hit on
a big possibly profitable idea they
assembled some space software and
science experts and set to work trying
to make life easier
on astronauts we got the minimun the
astronaut is not a scientist he need to
survive we need to be get into training
to sleep he cannot do too much science
space Pharma has built a shoebox size
laboratory that will hitch rides into
orbit on rockets from companies like
SpaceX the goal is to shrink down
state-of-the-art scientific equipment
and automate how it runs experiments
this would allow a great deal more
science to take place on the
International Space Station
so we're gonna go in the lab okay thank
you for the booties you're very welcome
so it's a pretty small bio lab but the
equipment's big and this you can't bring
to space so the whole idea of what we're
trying to do what we're really going to
look at is how we take this equipment
and bring it down to the small scale the
typical laboratory has refrigerator size
machines microscopes pipettes and a host
of liquids and chemicals it's a very
manual messy process that's tough enough
to pull off here on earth we just looked
at all that large equipment this is what
we fitted in research done on the ISS
has already led to the development of
new drugs and insights about organisms
molecules floating about freely and
solutions can behave more naturally than
when they're smeared flat on a petri
dish
every day our life is dominated by this
lens of gravity what goes up must come
down we remove that lens of gravity and
we learn something new space Pharma
wants to use its machines to let
companies and researchers conduct dozens
of different kinds of experiments and to
see what space can teach us to pull
myself out of the clouds and learn more
about Israel startup culture I went for
a walk on the beach back in Tel Aviv
with another local tech legend thank you
very much
Thanks armed with a law degree and an
MBA a D so fair tani had led a number of
young companies and helped spur on
israel's technology economy now she runs
facebook's israel operations today we
have something like 5,300 startups in
israel by the way it's there's no one
country in the world that has that
amount of startups except the u.s. yeah
it's 1,400 new startups in 2015
1,400 new status
women must serve alongside men in the
military here adhi once hoped to fly
jets but because of the gender
restrictions at the time she ended up
evaluating who could become a pilot she
sees the time in the Air Force as
crucial to her career
what's the uniqueness of the female
experience in Israel because of the
military service it must have some
long-term effects yeah I absolutely
think it as women in Israel and probably
start their career life with more
confidence with feeling that they also
can but are we done in Israel in terms
of women taking part no we're not and I
think that in Israel we'll probably
because of the military because of
startup nation because of the culture I
think that we'll probably closer to
achieve that but we are definitely
staying out there after our chat the D
insisted that I go revel in Tel Aviv's
famous nightlife and I'd never be one to
turn down such sound advice
tel-aviv stands out is one of the great
surprises of my travels
it's a city teeming with laughter music
and an energetic hum the action
stretches across dozens of colorful
neighborhoods with a Mediterranean feel
people head out late here often starting
dinner at 9:00 p.m. the bartender's look
for any excuse to do shots with their
patrons and their patrons release this
patron look for any excuse to oblige the
beach the old city the boardwalk joy
rides this is a wondrous place the feels
at times as if it exists within its own
bubble separate from the rest of the
country next up I travel to Jerusalem
and visit a start-up that puts a new
twist on peering into the future it's a
little disorienting at first to try to
play a video game just by moving your
head
this is the port district of Tel Aviv
it's a popular shopping area and the
perfect place to meet up with Dror
Sharona a former member of the air force
and now the founder of consumer physics
the company raised 2.7 million dollars
via a huge Kickstarter campaign so that
it could produce a device called the
saya
which may soon change the way we shop
for groceries when you think about it
how do you make your selection today
grab it and feel that out further it is
so it's good yeah you know you might
want to have some scientific back into
what you're doing right
the saya replaces your grandmother's
squeeze test sorry grandma to tell you
the best cucumber or tomato to pick in
an instant it displays the food's
calorie fat and sugar content it's the
quickest way to finding the perfect
potato that's cool it's really and you
can actually tell yourself everybody's
like some Star Trek the spectrometer
usually looks like this it's a big ol
hunk of scientific gear that can peer
into things and determine their
properties rather incredibly Bisaya
shrinks much of the same technology down
onto a chip it zaps an object with
near-infrared light stirs up its
molecules and tells a story about the
object as people go around zapping
things with the Scio the objects get put
into a database this then becomes a
giant log of all the materials in our
world
that sounds all well and good but how
would the CEO fare against one of
mankind's most mysterious creations this
is the cheese test good ol American
Velveeta labels the labels to 90 here's
three others it's almost flat out that's
the fat percentage on the label 23 in
your 25 the sales value should go well
beyond kumquats and industrialized
cheese it can help farmers decide when
to harvest their crops it can detect
watered-down fuel at Shady gas stations
and it can tell real medicine for fake
pills when you think of health care
actually it's not about what you're
buying is actually tracking your
well-being over time and instead of
sending stuff to the lab you'll actually
be able to measure it on yourself drawer
even sees a future for this device in
your bathroom you can measure teeth you
can measure saliva can measure hair you
can measure urine the Badgers the other
thing so I mean there's there's a ton of
stuff and people are coming at the days
and they use it for technical trials so
I'm gonna take my smart phone into the
toilet well it'll be probably inside
your toilet away all right yeah that
makes sense from the Cosmopolitan coast
I climbed the winding mountain road to
Jerusalem
tel-aviv maybe the beating heart of the
Israeli tech world but most Jews
consider Jerusalem to be the country's
sole
naturally you know what they say about
the soul
if you think about it the most basic
thing of human communication is is I
conduct by the device seeing you you get
a whole other world of interaction the
window to the soul
window exactly the window to the soul or
the window to the brain look around look
to the right look to the left you see
Kempinski is the co-founder and CEO of
youmove based here in jerusalem the
company has developed a way to replace
eye tracking gear that usually cost tens
of thousands of dollars with algorithms
that can run on an iPad or smartphone
it's a little disorienting at first to
try to play a video game just by moving
your head so you see head movement I
movement
iris movement blinks and then and then
analysis of that Kempinski hopes the
technology will give us new rapid
insights into conditions like
concussions so this is like when they
shot in the white light that you have to
follow I'm using doctors doing that
exactly and then based on the score we
can tell if I have a confession that I
don't you don't have them I don't have a
concussion Kempinski thinks that these
hard science applications with
real-world uses distinguish Israel's
tech scene especially for Jerusalem
startups people are looking for you know
real deep tech can't say I'm you know
making an app for taking pictures of
food you have to give up you know a real
explanation to your Jewish grandmother
about what what is that for
this is the Damascus Gate it's not that
far at all from where we were earlier
today there's a sniper up in the window
who's guarding against a lot of the
recent stabbings that have been going on
Jerusalem's trying to turn into a
technology city and this is the reality
of how these businesses have to come to
life in this type of environment
the moment you step into Jerusalem it's
clear that the city carries with it the
weight of thousands of years of history
everyone in the Middle East and by
extension the world has their eyes fixed
here unalaq's a mosque on the Wailing
Wall on the spot where it's believed
Jesus was crucified
this is a small spot of land with
outsized global importance under heavy
guard carved into minut slices and
fortified with walls those barriers went
up to curb violence based on ancient
disputes seen another way they've become
blockades that hold back
modern opportunity
I traveled north from Jerusalem to
Nazareth the largest Arab Enclave in
Israel the place with a laid-back vibe
and a very specific flavor we can see a
10 or 15 places just for Shalimar
so because of that I call it the
shawarma value our prepare you have the
Silicon Valley we have the shawarma well
yeah we are at the middle of the shore
Mullen
that's funny sweetheart he open Israel's
first Arab tech accelerator and he knows
everyone in town even ha wah what cool
Arabs do not have to serve in the
military and lack the tech connection
supplied by the IDF Fadi is set to work
trying to fix this and to help Arab
engineers benefit from Israel's tech
boom in a controversial move he's
linking them up with the tech moguls who
have come out of the IDF's
unit 8200 the spooky security and
espionage bugs anyone is going out with
a two hundred best thing is thinking
about this to make you stock up they to
undergraduates have a special NGO that
helped them at our community it's not so
popular to have suffer because the - you
know industry it's very risky body is a
rebel he was the only Arab in his class
at the Technion Israel's elite Technical
University inside of this building he
shepherded dozens of like-minded
engineers they're building software
consumer services and hardware in an
effort to make sure that the Arab
speaking world has the latest and great
technology I think if we can be part of
the ecosystem in Tel Aviv and we'll be
part of the startup nation we can raise
the standard of life of our community
here because Israel is known as this
startup nation but it's left out a big
chunk of people so exactly there's two
communities the arabs and the jewish
orthodox the government now is putting
some money to find the ways how to
engage them with a sort of nation here
because they believe that if we are not
part of that the startup nation will be
somehow slowed here and it cannot
continue to be the second place after
the Silicon Valley a handful of his
companies have already taken off and
made headway and billion dollar
industries but it's proven tough for
them to find investment dollars there's
a clear bias against Arab companies and
many of their backers have opted to
remain anonymous where to funnel their
investments through offshore accounts
but Fadi remains optimistic they hope in
the coming years maybe we have big
success stories let's say the first
unicorn startup from the olive community
may be here in Israel this may began
attract more and more interpreters to be
part of that and like other businessmen
to be part of this industry
and that hopeful note my time in Israel
came to an end it's understandable that
tourists have made fewer visits here in
recent months that the markets have
grown quieter and the mood in the
streets more tense this place can seem
daunting from afar to visit Israel
though is to experience the
extraordinary so many parts of our
nature joy conflict conformity and
imagination swirl around together in
confounding and inspiring ways I'm not
sure that anyone will really ever make
sense of all this but it's spectacular
to witness and feel even if just for a
short while as for my next stop well
that would be Iceland home of alien
landscapes an astonishing amount of fish
and space war boys
you